[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Christy
is in Phoenix Hi chrisy how are you good
how are you better than I deserve what's
up well my husband and I own a franchise
it's a restaurant um don't really want
to say the name but we have a business
loan a pretty hefty business
loan which so our we owe 230 on the
business MH and we have about that
exactly 230 equity in our home would you
sell your home to pay off the business
loan because the interest rate just
keeps going up and up and up and our
payments are now we've owned this
restaurant for three and a half years
and we started paying 2500 a month and
now we are at 4500 a month because of
the interest
rate would you sell your house to P off
your business
loan are you making
money yes we're making money but how
much what's your pro what's your taxable
income in 2023 going to
be like take homes no taxable income
what are you goingon to pay taxes onx
what's your tax return going to tell me
you made the real profit of the real
profit maybe like
700,000 why don't you just pay it
off you're going to pay taxes on
$700,000 profit
maybe not that maybe not profit that
might be gross rev numers that might be
gross revenue that might be that might
be you're right what do you take home do
you know
that out of the business we pay
ourselves a salary from the business
yeah what is that and that's about um
45,000 each and then he retired from the
Army so he has each sorry um no together
so you make a $45,000 salary okay at the
end of the year was there
$600,000 laying around in an
account no then you did not make a
$700,000
profit okay then no I'm I'm really
profit is what you what the B not pro
Prof gross revenue is the total money
coming in then minus expenses equals
profit does that make sense yes okay and
I hope to God you made more than $45,000
on $700,000 worth of income I think do
you guys have money laying around in
any savings for the business we do R so
so right now to get us through our
winter we live where it's kind of it's
hard to make it through the winter so we
have 50,000 to get us through the winter
this coming winter and 25,000 we just
put away for savings and then we have
another that's in a savings account then
we have another 25,000 in
cash okay so it's a little hard for for
me to tell you what to do cuz I can't
figure out whether you're making any
money or not you've been doing this
three years and it sounds like you've
gathered up about was here and then he
had to go to the dentist otherwise he
knows all that he does all the numbers
and stuff so here's here's the let me
kind of give you the concept and then
you and your husband can talk through it
the concept is I would sell my home only
if I can't figure out a way to clear
this debt in about 3 years which means
you would need to make more than more
than you know you after you pay your
bills and eat you'd need to make an
extra $75 to $100,000 a year to throw at
this
loan okay and I don't know if this
restaurant is producing that or not it
doesn't sound like it is so it does
sound like you have made a mistake and
you've overpaid for this franchise and
this mess you've gotten yourself into
and it probably cost you your home
you're probably going to have to sell
your home or you're going to end up
bankrupt is this the only m is the
business the only money coming in or do
you guys have other side jobs she he has
he had military retirement okay a
military retirement yeah is that
it yes okay yeah yeah you guys need to
figure out but it sounds like you guys
are making maybe $100,000 a year off of
this total including the money you're
setting back and the money you're taking
home and all that um and that that means
you're probably going to have this debt
around for four five six years if you
keep your house so the fact that you
overpaid for this restaurant you got
excited and the fact that you went into
debt to buy the restaurant uh and which
you should not have done by the way um
then then I would not have done this
deal uh uh but you're there now yeah
those things are forcing you to sell
your
house um so it's as if at the beginning
of this whole project you
said I want to own this restaurant more
than I want to own my house you didn't
mean to say that but that's what it come
it's what it's going to come down to and
so unless you guys can figure out that
you can pull a 100,000 75 to
100,000 out of the business and throw it
at the debt and still pay your bills at
home and eat for the next two to three
years if you can do that for three years
you're out of debth MH okay and but I
don't think this thing's generating that
now maybe it will start but the fact
that you have down Winters in the
restaurant business is weird yeah I I
felt the same
yeah I had I had more questions but you
know I think 45 to to earn 45,000 a year
off a business just doesn't feel worth
it it's not they're they're making more
than that but not much